Um,
I started last time and actually my whole lecture existed under the rubric of
this quotation from Sabbath Lily hawks.
And I'm just gonna read it to you again.
Um,
I like his eyes.
They don't look like they see what he's looking at,
but they keep on looking.
So last time I suggested that what O'Connor asks us to see in her fiction is a
theological structure and a religious message.
What I started to suggest at the end of class,
as I gave you the catalog of body parts lying around the text,
what I began to suggest is that if we actually see what we're looking at rather
than like Hay's not seeing what we're looking at,
we begin to see something that's harder to assimilate to that neat theology that
O'connor's letters and essays point us towards.
One kind of question then I was raising is what context do you use to read any
novel?
And today I'm going to suggest to actually,
well yes,
two additional contexts that we can look to,
to read the novel.
And I will,
uh,
I will let you know what those are when they,
when they come.
But be looking for that.
So 200 people show up to see esal hawks blind himself.
That's what we're told.
That's what the newspaper clipping tells us.
We show up to see O'Connor take her character's apart.
I began that catalog of body parts.
Today I'm going to extend and embellish the catalog of suffering and distortion
that we see in this novel.
And just to remind you of that catalog,
I just want to look at page 43 in your addition 47 in mine.
Um,
I noted that a lot of the potty body parts that we see in her pros are,
are parts of women's bodies.
Well,
the sense of the body as grotesque goes beyond just dismemberment.
There's a general ugliness of women that pertains in the novel.
And if you look on that page about in the middle,
this is Enoch describing his foster mother.
This woman was hard to get along with.
She wasn't old.
I reckon she was 40 year old,
but she,
but she show was ugly.
She had,
these are brown glasses and her hair was so thin.
It looked like Ham gravy trickling over her skull.
Okay.
It's funny a little bit.
It's a picture as comparison heron gravy.
Um,
but it emphasizes that ugliness.
Now if you look on page 80,
um,
84 in my edition,
yeah,
this is a woman climbing out of the swimming pool.
Remember when Hays and Enoch are in the middle of the park at the swimming pool,
you know,
hiding in the bushes,
spying on the women.
Um,
here's one climbing out of the pool.
Okay.
First her face appeared at the bottom of the page.
First or face appeared long and cadaverous with a bandage like bathing cap
coming down almost to her eyes and sharp teeth protruding from her mouth.
Then she rose on her hands until a large foot and leg came up from behind her
and another on the other side.
And she was out squatting there,
panting.
She stood up loosely and shook herself and stamped in the water dripping off of
her.
She,
she comports herself like a dog in this scene.
Okay.
So she shakes it as if she had for,
to shake.
Um,
but registered the weirdness of this sentence.
Then she rose on her hands until a large foot and leg came up from behind her.
It's as if they're sneaking up behind her.
It's as if they're separate from her,
not part of her body at all.
So even when you see O'connor describing the emergence of a body from the water,
a moment when you'd think the whole body would be most on view or most pertinent
to describe what you have is almost a distortion of our senses.
A distortion of vision,
so that we see even in a woman climbing out of the water,
her legs,
her feet as dismembered from the rest of her body.
Okay.
There is a critic at the University of Michigan.
Her name is Patricia Yeager.
She wrote a very compelling argument about O'Connor's fiction,
not about wise blood in particular,
but about her stories.
And in that essay she argues that O'Connor's grotesqueness,
especially the grotesqueness of the women,
uh,
figures in her novels is all wrapped up with a culture of southern womanhood.
It's a culture of beauty that requires all kinds of grooming practices to form
and shape the body in such a way that it can appear socially in a decorous way.
So Yeager argues that what we see in scenes like this is the registration of the
violence of those practices of beauty.
So she does not let these things sit in the text to be assimilated to a
theological structure,
but she brings them out.
And by reading things like,
um,
contemporaneous autobiographies from southern women that she's chosen from the
Canon,
um,
and just accounts of what was required of women,
etiquette and so on,
she weaves a reading of passages like this into that kind of context to suggest
that O'Connor's vision of violence has more to do with being a woman in the
south than it does with the stated religious concerns that O'Connor talks about
in her letters.
Now remember as I mentioned,
O'connor suffered from Lupus and she was disfigured by this disease especially.
She was on crutches for a long time and for periods of time could not walk at
all.
Her legs would swell up.
There's a lot of imagery of swelling,
of distortion and distension of the body that some critics point to her
biography to explain.
They look at her experience of her own body.
And when you think about Yeager's argument,
that kind of distortion of the body in the context of a social culture that
really emphasizes the control of a woman's body,
then you begin to see the power of the tension that we can read into moments
like this.
But I would suggest,
and actually Yeager suggest this too,
that the violence of southern culture goes way beyond just the violence of the
culture of femininity,
the culture of the southern woman.
And so let's look a little bit and extend the catalog.
Another category of violence we have is murdered children,
murdered,
and also just generally neglected or abandoned children.
Enoch,
if you'll recall,
was traded by his father off to the Bible woman with the gravy hair.
So that bespeaks the pain.
And last time I,
I,
um,
read you a passage where Enoch begins to tell that story in this very pitiful
way.
I'm getting no sympathy from Hays.
So clearly he feels the abandonment from his father.
If you look at,
um,
page one 20,
in your addition one 22,
if anyone has mine,
this is a little story that Sabbath Lily tells to Hays while they are,
um,
supposedly seducing each other.
Don't try this on your next date.
I don't think it works very well.
So this was her story.
There was this child wants,
she said,
turning over on her stomach that nobody cared if it lived or died.
It's kin centered around from one to another of them.
And finally to his grandmother,
who was a very evil woman and she couldn't stand to have it around because the
least good thing made her break out in these Wellbe's.
She would all itching and swole,
even her eyes would itch her and swell up and there wasn't nothing she could do,
but run up and down the road,
shaking her hands and cursing.
And it was twice as bad when this child was there.
So she kept the child locked up in a chicken crate.
It seen it's granny and hellfire,
swollen burning.
And it told her everything I had seen.
And she got so swollen until finally she went to the well and wrap the well rope
around her neck and let down the bucket and broke her neck.
What'd you guess me to be 15 year old?
She asked seductively.
Okay.
Yes.
Very romantic story.
Sabbath tells to our friend Hayes,
um,
these images of babies abandoned here.
It's called an it.
Children are often called it in O'connor's fiction especially I would note if
they're,
if they're female children,
uh,
normally called it.
Um,
Lily herself is a child who is completely unloved by her father.
Her father just wants to get rid of her and is willing to collude with her to
try to make,
uh,
to try to make Hayes take her off his hands.
And remember the story of her naming her mother gave birth to her on a Sunday
and right after she was born,
gave her the name Sabbath then turned on her side and died.
So poor Lilly is also,
uh,
an orphan,
at least in the emotional sense.
Um,
if not in actual reality,
her father of course had run off from her mother.
Um,
uh,
right after she had gotten pregnant and then I suppose he came back.
Um,
so children are deeply abused and neglected.
What else do we have on two 31?
Just to add to this catalog,
we have murdered,
abandoned,
neglected children.
We also have police brutality.
Um,
two 31.
Now,
let me see.
I may not have gotten the right page number for you guys for this one.
This is right when Hays has been found in the ditch by the two policemen.
And maybe you recall it.
Hayes asks,
uh,
whether it's day or night,
this is bottom of two 30.
It's a day.
The thinner one.
The cop said,
looking at the sky,
we got to take you back to pay your rent.
I want to go on where I'm going.
The blind man said,
you got to pay your rent first.
The policeman said every bit of it.
The other perceiving that he was conscious hit him over the head with his new
Billy.
We don't want to have no trouble with him.
He said,
you take his feet,
he died in the squad car but they didn't notice and took him on to the land.
Ladies,
she had put him in her bed and when she had pushed them out the door,
she locked it behind them and drew up a street chair and sat down close to his
face where she could talk to him.
Um,
here,
this image of a man obviously in indigent found on the road and then
gratuitously abused by the police echoes the earlier moment when the policeman
pushes his car off the road and,
and down the hill.
Yeah.
These are instances where police are using their power utterly on their own
authority with seemingly no check with point with,
with excess force.
Yeah.
Remember again,
this is the south.
We all know that these kinds of violence,
official violence were part and parcel of southern culture towards African
Americans.
Okay.
What I think O'Connor is doing here is taking some of that reality and injecting
it into Hayes's narrative.
So these are the kinds of images that the civil rights movement really brought
to light here.
We see them in relation to Hays,
but overt racism is there too.
And if you look on page 67 in your book,
and this is on 71 in mine,
yeah,
you will see that.
Yeah.
O'Connor does not hesitate to use the word nigger in the dialogue of her
characters.
Now the narrative voice does not use that word,
but here it is on the bottom of 71 her characters are perhaps typical poor
southerners.
Well,
what do you want to pay for it?
The man asks,
this is Hayes bises buying his Essex.
I wouldn't trade me a Chrysler for an Essex like that.
That car yonder ain't been built by a bunch of niggers.
All the niggers are living in Detroit now putting cars together.
He said making conversation.
I was up there a while myself and seen I come home.
Yeah,
she's invoking in a very casual way,
the southern racism of the poorer white,
uh,
working and,
and uh,
working class.
This is just part of her representation of the place,
part of her representation of these characters.
It's a kind of realism of course.
Nevertheless,
there it is in front of us.
And again,
I call you back to that quotation.
What are we going to see when we look at the fiction?
Do we see what's in front of us?
So this is one of the things that O'Connor puts in front of us on page one 74,
uh,
again,
you check in and see if this is the same in your addition.
Generally annoyingly,
it's sometimes four pages different earlier.
Sometimes it's too,
so I tried to get them all,
but I think I didn't look this one up.
This is Enoch stealing the new Jesus.
He had dark his face and hands with Brown shoe Polish so that if you were seeing
in the act he would be taken for a colored person.
Then he had sneaked into the museum while the guard was asleep and it broken the
glass case with a wrench he borrowed from his landlady,
then shaking and sweating.
He had lifted the shriveled man out and thrust him in a paper sack and had crept
out again past the guard who was still asleep.
He realized as soon as he got out of the museum that since no one had seen him
to think he was a colored boy,
he would be suspected immediately and would have to disguise himself.
That was why he had on the black beard and dark glasses.
Okay,
so there's a certain sense of humor here.
So Enoch goes in black face to commit the crime so that if he seen he won't be
taken for White,
but then he realizes a black person just by definition is suspicious.
So he has to now disguise himself from being a black person.
This is partly EasyKnock sort of craziness,
but the joke relies on the fact of racial profiling.
It relies on the fact that it's very plausible to think that at this moment in
the south,
to walk down the street as a black person,
to drive a car as a black person would be a risky endeavor in some places in the
city.
So it's a joke,
but it's a joke that rests on a very dark reality.
Okay.
So what you have then
is a set of things that were put before us that we are asked in a way not to
respond to.
Let's look at one more example.
This is on page one 59.
This is a silly example.
Yeah,
this is when Hoover shouts and note,
um,
in connection with my lecture last time I talked to you about pigs and why they
are pigs all over landscape.
Well,
whoever shouts a shout is a bay,
a little pig.
So she's continuing that metaphor with his name or that trope with his name.
This is a haze being approached by Hoover shouts,
my name is Hoover shouts the man with his head in the door growled.
I known when I first seen you that you wasn't nothing but a crack pot.
He's opened the door enough to be able to slam it.
Hoover showed Scott his head of the way but not his thumb.
Uh,
how all arose that would have rented almost any heart.
Hayes opened the door and release the thumb and then slammed the door again.
How arose that would rent almost any heart.
What you want to ask about.
All these things that I'm putting in front of you are,
are they supposed to rent our hearts?
I don't think we're meant to feel much for Hoover shouts here.
He's a figure of critique.
He's a figure of a of satire.
He's the charlatan preacher.
We're certainly not meant to identify with him or to sympathize with him,
but here you can't help but thinking about someone getting their thumbs smashed
in the door and then it gets more intense.
Of course,
on page two oh six
okay,
that's two Oh four and in this edition,
yeah,
when Hays commits murder,
so here we have the murder scene
take off that suit.
Hayes shouted and started the car forward after him,
solace began to Lope down the road,
taking off his coat as he went,
take it all off.
Hayes yelled with his face close to the windshield.
The prophet began to run in earnest.
He tore off his shirt and unbuckled his belt and ran out of his trousers.
He began grabbing for his feet as if he would take off his shoes too,
but before he could get at them,
the Essex knocked him flat and ran over him.
Hayes drove about 20 feet and stopped the car and then began to back it.
He backed it over the body and then stopped and got out.
The ESIC stood half over the other profit as if it were pleased to guard what
had had finally brought down.
The man didn't look so much like Hayes lying on the ground with his face on his
face without his hat or suit on.
A lot of blood was coming out of him and forming a puddle around his head.
He was motionless all but for one finger that moved up and down in front of his
face as if he were marking time with it.
Haze poked his toe and his side and he wheezed for a second and then was quiet.
Two things I can't stand.
Hayes said a man that ain't true and one that mocks what is,
you shouldn't ever have tampered with me if you didn't want what you've got.
The man was trying to say something,
but he was only wheezing.
Hey is squatted down by his face to listen.
Give my mother a lot of trouble.
He said through a kind of bubbling in his throat,
never give her no rest.
Stole their car,
never told true to my daddy.
Give Henry what never give up.
You shut up.
Hayes said,
leaning his head closer to hear the confession to old where it still was.
Got $5 for it.
The men gasped.
You shut up now.
Hey said Jesus,
the man said,
shut up now.
Like I told you,
hey,
said Jesus,
help me.
The man we used,
Hayes gave him a hard slap on the back and he was quiet.
How many of you,
when you read that felt like a character who mattered to you had died?
Just so you guys are exceptionally,
exceptionally sympathetic.
I commend you.
It's hard to feel too much for this prophet and I would argue that his
confession at the end is part of what makes it quite difficult.
It's such a kind of trivial set of things that he begins to recite,
or at least he recites them in such a cliched way.
I gave my mother trouble.
I was a bad boy.
Uh,
I took some money to tell where the still was.
These are such sort of cliched southern Isms that you start to see this
character as a caricature.
He's very hard to see as a human being.
And yet I would contend that the part about the Essex actually running over him
is,
is quite compelling.
At least I feel it when I read it in a more abstract sense.
I feel the violence of it when I read those passages.
So there's a sense in which you have to ask,
is this meant to rand our hearts?
If Hoover shows thumb in the door,
doesn't quite do it.
Does this do it?
Yeah.
Does southern racism do it?
Does the dismemberment of women do it?
What is the point of putting these on the page?
And if you think about the way some bodies literally explode,
think of the new Jesus.
Remember when Hays takes that little shriveled body from Lilly and throws it
against the wall,
the head pops and outcomes,
dust and trash.
Yeah.
If bodies are exploding here,
why are we not asked to care?
And if we aren't asked to care,
what is it that we're asked to do or to think in response to these things now.
Okay.
Patricia Yeager in her argument,
rejects what has typically been offered up as a way to account for these things.
And that's the religious reading.
She says to dismiss that violence,
it's
into an old and comfortable theology is simply not to see it,
not really to see it,
not to notice that O'Connor put it there in such a sharp and compelling form.
I want to change tack for a minute and now I'm going to veer into that second
kind of context that I said I was gonna talk about today.
There is something else I think we're meant to see that is neither theology nor
southern context.
And I want to show you that now by looking at chapter seven starts on one 15 in
your book,
a one 17 in this edition.
Yeah.
Just want to read the opening.
I'm going to treat this chapter as a sort of microcosm of the book with respect
to its craft.
Yeah.
Let's look at how this opens.
The next afternoon when he got his car back,
he drove it out into the country to see how well it worked on the open road.
The Sky was just a little lighter blue than his suit.
Clear.
And even with only one cloud in it,
a large blinding white one with curls and a beard.
Notice that image of the cloud,
the blinding white cloud.
Yeah.
It's very hard not to see it as a symbol.
What kind of symbol is it?
Well,
it's a god symbol.
It's
even got that typical children's book iconography of the curls and the white
beard.
Okay.
So this is like your children's book representation of the Christian God,
and there it is as a blinding white cloud.
You wouldn't even need the curls and the beard.
Yeah.
If you just had the blinding in the white.
And of course,
uh,
as we go on,
as I'll show you,
the curls in the beard are pared away.
And your,
your left more with that blinding whiteness.
Yeah.
So the blinding white cloud begins this chapter and what happens of course
thereafter as you'll remember,
is that lily pops up from the back seat.
Hi.
She,
he didn't know that she was there and she's got a hand full of Dandelions and
she's painted her mouth read with lipstick and she's trying to seduce him.
And he had in fact given her this little,
um,
sort of seductive note,
earlier suggesting that he wanted to seduce too.
And he still has in his mind that he should do this.
And his point is to do it so that he will prove that he needs no redemption and
that there is no sin.
The problem here is that lily is interested in the seduction precisely because
she sees it as a kind of sin.
Yeah.
So if the,
to enter into this seduction,
they do so agreeing on the same act,
but completely diametrically opposed on its theological meaning or it's
metaphysical meaning.
And so what you'll notice in this chapter is an extended example in one of the
only extended conversations of the book of that phenomenon I talked about last
time,
where the characters just,
uh,
don't seem to register the existence of the other person at all.
So Hayes,
as I argue last time,
is kind of insulated.
Even his senses are insulated.
He can't hear things,
he doesn't see what's in front of him.
He doesn't seem to be in his context physically at all.
He doesn't seem to register the pain of other persons.
Sometimes he doesn't even seem to register the existence of other persons.
Well,
this is an example.
This conversation have completely missed signals between the two of them.
Sabbath Lily tells the story of wrestling with her identity as a bastard.
And on one 19,
you get her account of her writing to the advice columnist Mary Brittle about
the problem of being a bastard.
And what kind of sexual play is appropriate for a bastard given the fact that
the Bible says a bastard shall not enter the Kingdom of heaven.
So she's trying to figure out really whether she should sleep with someone
because you know,
what does she have to lose?
She can't get into heaven anyway.
So she says,
Dear Mary,
I am a bastard in a bastard shall not enter the Kingdom of heaven as we all
know.
But I have this personality that makes boys follow me.
Do you think I should neck or not?
I shall not enter the Kingdom of heaven anyway,
so I don't see what difference it makes.
And then she writes back,
Mary,
brutal,
dear Sabbath light necking is acceptable.
But I think your real problem is one of adjustment to the modern world.
Perhaps you ought to reexamine your religious values to see if they meet your
needs in life or religious experience can be a beautiful addition to living if
you put it in the proper perspective and do not let it.
I think this is a misprint.
Do you have there?
Uh,
I think it's warp.
Warp.
You read some books on ethical culture.
Clearly O'connor is offering us Mary Brittle as the butt of her critique.
The shallow modern thinking of the enlightened psychologically and ethically
modern person
Sabbath in this figure in this chapter is,
is an odd Christ figure.
She is a Christ figure.
Remember how she hides and skips from tree to tree in this scene when she's
teasing Hayes towards the end of it?
Well,
that tree is also the image of the cross that uh,
that is,
um,
part of Christian tradition.
There are lots of hymns that talk about the tree as the cross or the cross as
the tree,
um,
for example.
But it's the figure,
the ragged figure that moves from tree to tree in the back of Hayes's mind.
That's the Christ that won't let him get away.
So Lily actually embodies that Christ like figure.
So for all her
impurity,
yeah.
O'Connor presents her in contrast to marry brittle as understanding something
fundamental about the world and what's important in the world that,
um,
that much more plausible people don't understand.
Okay.
So this is a moment when Sabbath tempt Hays back to belief and Hayes's
meditation on or his wrestling with the question in this chapter of whether a
bastard can be in the church without Christ.
And he comes to that point where he says,
no,
a bastard can't be part of the Church without Christ because the word bastard
would just simply not mean anything.
So you can't say that
and it takes them a long time to wrestle with this as Sabbath.
Lily talks to him and he comes to this moment and so when he comes to that
conclusion,
he also rejects her advances.
It's coming to that conclusion that's so preoccupies him that he rejects her
advances Sabbath.
If she had been able to seduce him.
I want to suggest O'Connor I think is suggesting would have drawn him back into
the realm of belief.
What leads,
what leads Hayes on
through this scene is that blinding white cloud.
Here it is as they decide whether to turn off the road and enter the field where
Sabbath,
we'll try to complete the seduction.
The blinding white cloud is a little ahead of them.
Moving to the left.
Why don't you turn that down?
That dirt road,
she asked the highway forked off onto a clay road and he turned onto it.
It was hilly and shady in the country,
showed two advantage on either side.
One side was dense honeysuckle,
the other was open and slanted down to telescoped view of the city.
The white cloud was directly in front of them.
So here the city is at a distance.
We're in a pastoral space,
a beautiful space.
And this is all sort of under the guidance of this white cloud,
this blinding white cloud.
And of course,
you know,
I don't have to say to you,
I'm sure,
blinding white cloud.
Why is this the blinding white cloud?
Well,
this is all about blinding.
This book.
It's about aces,
failed blinding of himself for Christ.
And it's about in the end finally Hayes's successful,
blinding a kind of blinding that um,
I would argue were meant understand as a final clarity of vision that to be
blind is to see properly.
So the blinding white cloud has this cliched,
God had imagery,
the curls and beard in the beginning.
It takes on this leading aspect in the middle of the chapter.
And then if you look at the end,
yeah.
Uh,
this is at the very end of the chapter.
A few pages on
this is after the man from the filling station has given haze some gas and not
charged him for it,
a very unusual act of kindness in this novel.
Um,
he leaves the haze,
drove on leaving the,
the man,
uh,
who has helped him.
The blinding white cloud had turned into a bird with long thin wings and was
disappearing in the opposite direction.
There's a perfect circularity to this symbolism.
It's at the beginning,
it changes in the middle and arrives at the end.
And by the end it has changed from the cliched image of the Christian God to a
less farcically cliched image of the Holy Spirit.
The bird ascending the white bird.
It's moving in the opposite direction,
suggesting that haze in this scene has missed his chance.
It was presiding over Sabbath.
Lily's attempt to seduce and he was so absorbed in the question of whether a
bastard could be in the church without Christ,
that he doesn't follow her into the sin that would in fact be the catalyst for
his redemption.
And so the cloud departs at the end.
I have to say this is incredibly heavy handed.
If we think about the religious reading and think about religious symbolism,
this is hardly innovative.
Okay,
and I would suggest to you that O'Connor,
well,
I don't know,
did O'Connor know that it was heavy handed?
I don't know.
What is true about O'connor is that she was trained to write stories like this.
Flanner O'Connor,
and this is again that context coming in.
Flannery O'connor was a student at the Iowa writer's workshop,
very prestigious writing program.
Even then,
it was a very prestigious writing program.
There is a peculiarity for writing in the second half of the 20th century,
and here I'm drawing on another critic from Ucla.
His name is mark [inaudible] girl.
He has argued that what is historically novel about this period
is that writers have consistently been located in universities.
They've been trained at universities.
They have taught at universities,
they have gone to creative writing programs,
embedded within universities.
They have held visiting positions,
they've done readings and they have written books whose primary readership is
around a seminar table or intellectual hall like this.
His argument is that a kind of formal structure characterized by the principle
of unity,
a formal structure that was in that simplified version that was at the very
heart of the most powerful critical movement of the early 20th century and that
is the new criticism.
The new criticism is a,
a way of reading that was has its roots in high modernism and it emphasizes the
writers,
usually the poets,
the poets ability to create a beautiful whole consistent internally structured
literary object that stands outside of history in a certain way that is
autonomous.
Yeah,
and so this view of the artwork,
probably you have experienced it if you've taken other English classes and in
fact I've been producing it for you in my readings.
This motive reading looks for those tropes that unify a work.
It looks for that circularity that I've described in this little chapter tracks
the symbols.
There's more to it than that.
It also looks for ambiguity.
Oh,
Connor says about her symbols that they should keep on deepening,
that they should never be reduced to a simple equation.
X Equals y cloud equals God,
that they should have a sense of mystery about them.
Well,
this was part and parcel of what a new critical reading practice would look
like.
And it's still extremely powerful in our classrooms.
We do a lot of close readings now.
We put our close readings to different kinds of uses.
And Mark,
my girl has done readings of lots of different novelists that reveal,
or his argument is that they reveal how the writing program and its tenants have
shaped contemporary fiction in a profound way.
The implications of this are large and important for how we understand the
period.
Yeah.
So what you see in O'connor is,
uh,
to borrow a phrase from girls title,
on his,
uh,
his essay on this,
um,
Flannery O'Connor,
B a m f,
a,
the product of a,
of a mid century American institution.
The writing program.
Yeah.
I would suggest,
and this is the third kind of context,
uh,
I want to give you today that the three I've given you
O'Connor's letters,
her theological commitments,
southern context,
southern social context,
the new critical writing program,
the institutionalization of modernism.
Yeah.
These things are not in fact separable from one another.
Okay.
Because in my own work,
I'm writing a book on religion and fiction since 1960.
Now,
this is a little bit before this period,
but what I have discovered,
what is really been known for a long time,
but nobody's really made much of it,
is that the new criticism is deeply religious in and of itself,
new critical writers of theory.
Many of them were in fact Catholic and many of them were southern.
There are social and religious elements that infuse their literary theory.
So that to argue that the poem is this unified whole
and that what you should do with a poem is show it's Honus read it in order to
see its wholeness.
See how it embodies a formal beauty,
a formal order.
This looks very much like the kind of metaphysical order that I was drawing out
of the Catholic version of what O'Connor's doing in her novels,
her version of what she's doing in the novels where you have that transcendent
sky.
And there's this sense of an ordering that seeps down into the material world.
That moment when Hays thinks that he's somehow,
uh,
seeing broken off pieces of something that once happened to him.
There's this latent order everywhere.
And for O'connor,
it's part of this moral religious order,
this redemptive order that Catholicism,
uh,
is for her.
The new criticism sits in a kind of
a deep analogy to that way of thinking about religion.
That's why I think O'Connor founded so,
uh,
comfortable to learn and practice the new critical tenants of formal,
construction of the literary.
That's why she produced story after story after story that can be read in these
formal ways with these symbols that accrue meaning and deepen and change over
the course of the novel or the story.
So her commitment to the new criticism girl argues that,
um,
that O'Connor found the new criticism comfortable because Catholicism had taught
her to be obedient,
that it was a matter of obedience to a formula that allowed her to produce what
she produced on the page.
I would argue with differently that there is something in fact,
religious about the new criticism that made it particularly comfortable for
O'connor two and habit.
Now I want to conclude by pointing you towards Lolita.
Today the question of torturing your own characters has come up.
Yeager calls it with respect to O'connor and aesthetics of torture.
I want you to think hard about whether this is a way of understanding Lolita
when we read it,
so have that in your mind and think about the ways that violence is or is not
presented to us in Lolita.
The way that we're asked either to attend to language or to see through it,
ask those questions about whether we're being asked to identify with certain
characters or not.
How is the distance between reader and character between reader and what's on
the page?
How's that mediated?
How's that policed?
How's that structured?
So think about that as you start to read Lolita.
Um,
I'm going to stop there.